bueno muy buenos días pues efectivamente
lo que volodymyr es the lens que viene a
pedir aquí en europa después de todos
estos días de esta campaña diplomática
es para poder tener digamos el apoyo de
los grandes a países de occidente ss que
le abran las puertas tanto de la otan
como de la unión europea algo que no va
a ser muy fácil porque a pesar de que
aunque han estado en conversaciones con
la otan
jens stoltenberg el secretario general
de esa organización atlántico norte pues
había dicho que efectivamente cuentan
con el ucranio cuenta con el apoyo de la
otan pero por ahora se mantiene como
éste es socio con digamos relaciones
mejoradas más no como uno de los 30
miembros de esta de la otan y por otra
parte pues la unión europea todavía hay
muchas reticencias en el seno de los 27
países que no ven con muy buenos ojos la
entrada a ucrania y de hecho el
secretario de estado francés de asuntos
europeos dijo hace poco que aunque
ucrania cuenta con el apoyo de francia
lo cierto es que por ahora pues no ven
como una perspectiva clara la adición de
ucrania a la bloque euro
pero como usted bien lo decía pues el
esquí lo que dice y lo que tiene como
argumento es que para preservar la
seguridad europea pues hay que preservar
también la seguridad de ucrania pero tan
tal y además cuéntenos cómo pueden
-francia y alemania- aminorar esta ola
de tensiones en la frontera entre rusia
y ucrania que ya está generando un temor
de conflicto en varias regiones del
planeta
así es pues digamos que la estrategia de
vladimir putin ahí en toda esa frontera
en el noroeste en toda la región también
de tumbas pues tiene que ser digamos lo
que se llama como wait and see o sea
esperar y vamos a ver qué pasa con
pequeñas provocaciones esperando una
respuesta bélica por parte de ucrania
por ahora no se ha dado como ustedes
bien recuerdan pues eeuu ha tratado de
entrar ahí a mediar
joe biden pidió hace unos días a putin
que haya una reunión en un país tercero
acerca de este conflicto que pueden
hacer francia alemania bueno estos dos
países han servido como mediadores en
los últimos años desde que comenzó este
conflicto en el 2014 y por ese entonces
en junio hubo una reunión en normandía
en la región de normandía aquí en a
francia y desde allí digamos que se
conoce esto como el formato de normandía
en donde es una reunión en la que está
pues ucrania rusia que son pues las
partes importantes ahí y en los que
tanto alemania como francia han servido
de mediación lo que quiere aquí es de
lenski el presidente ucraniano es que
tanto marco como merkel pues le den un
impulsó precisamente a este formato para
que haya una reunión y los cuatro países
puedan discutir acerca de esta esta
situación que se está viviendo allí en
la frontera y que por supuesto pues se
va aumentando también las tensiones en
europa y en el mundo